when a pot is scheduled by kubernetes is
important that containers have enough
resources to actually run if you
schedule a large app on a node with
limited resources it's possible the node
runs out of memory or CPU and things
just stop working in this episode of
kubernetes best practices let's take a
look at how you can solve these problems
using resource requests and limits
[Music]
requests and limits are the mechanisms
kubernetes uses to control resources
such as CPU and memory requests are what
the container is guaranteed to get if a
container requests a resource kubernetes
will only schedule it on a node that can
give it that resource limits on the
other hand make sure container never
goes above a value the container is only
allowed to go up to the limit and then
it's restricted let's see how these work
so there's two types of resources CPU
and memory the kubernetes scheduler uses
these to figure out where to run your
pots a typical spec for a pod for
resources might look something like this
each container in the pod can set its
own requests and limits and these are
all additive CPU resources are defined
in MillerCoors if your container needs
to full courser on you'd put the value
2000 m if your container only needs 1/4
of a core you would put a value of 250 m
one thing to keep in mind is that if you
put a value in let's larger than the
core account of your biggest node then
your pod will never be scheduled let's
say you have a pod that needs 4 cores
but your kubernetes cluster it's just
comprised of 2 core VMs in this case
your pod will never be scheduled so
unless your app is specifically designed
to take advantage of multiple cores you
know things like scientific computing x'
and some databases come to mind it's
usually a best practice to keep the cpu
requests at 1 or below and then run more
replicas to scale it out this gives the
system more flexibility and more
reliability when it comes to CPU limits
things get interesting
so CPUs consider a compressible resource
if your app starts hitting your CPU
limits Cooper noise will start to
throttle your container this means your
CPU will be artificially restricted
giving your app potentially worse
performance however it won't be
terminated or evicted memory resources
are defined in bytes normally you give a
meby byte value from memory but you can
give it from anything from bytes to
petabytes just like CPU if you put a
memory request that's larger than the
amount of memory on your nodes the pod
will never be scheduled now unlike
CPU resources memory is not compressible
because there's no way to throttle
memory usage the container goes past
this memory limit
it'll be terminated it's important to
remember that you cannot set requests
that are larger than the resources
provided by your nodes you can find the
total resources for gke VMs at this link
in an ideal world the container settings
would be good enough to take care of
everything but the world it's a dark and
terrible place people can easily forget
to set their resources or a rogue team
can set their requests and limits are
very high and take up more than their
fair share of the cluster to prevent
these scenarios you can set up resource
quotas and limit ranges after creating a
namespace you can lock them down using
quotas for example if you have a
production and development namespace a
common pattern is to put no quota on
production and then put very strict
quotas on the development namespace this
allows production to take all the
resource that it needs in case of a
spike in traffic and development is
locked down a quota for resources might
look something like this in this example
you can see that there are four sections
let's go into each one request that CPU
is the maximum combined CPU request that
all containers in the namespace can have
so in this example you can have 50
containers with 10m requests 5
containers with 100 ml requests or just
1 container with 500 m of requests as
long as the total requested CPU in the
namespace is less than 500 m we're good
to go
request that memory is the maximum
combined memory request that all
containers in the namespace can have so
again in the above example you can have
50 containers with 2 and might be
requests 5 containers with 20 MB
requests or just 1 container with a
hundred as long as the total requested
memory in the namespace is less than 100
movie bytes limits up CPU is some
maximum combined CPU limits that all the
containers and namespaces can have you
know it's just like requests at CPU but
for the limits and then finally limits
up memory is the maximum combined memory
limits of all containers in a namespace
can have again just like the requests on
memory but for a limit instead
you can also create a limit range in
your namespace unlike a quota which
looks at the whole namespace a limit
range enforces itself on individual
containers so this can help prevent
people from creating super tiny or super
large containers inside the namespace a
limit range might look something like
this so looking at an example you can
see again there's four sections let's go
into each one the default section will
set up the default limits for a
container in the pot if you set these
values in the limit range any containers
that don't explicitly set these values
themselves well get assigned the default
values the default request section will
set up the default requests for a
container in a pot again if you set
these values in the limit range any
container so they'll explicitly set
these themselves will get assigned these
default values the max section will set
up the maximum limits that a container
and a pod can set the default section
cannot be set higher than this value and
the limits in the container cannot be
higher as well it's important to note
that if this value is set and the
default section is not set the max value
becomes the default value as well the
min section will set up the minimum
request of a container in a pod consent
the default request section cannot be
lower than this and requests that on a
container cannot be lower as well again
it's important to note that if this
value is set and the default request
section is not set the minimum value
becomes the default request as well so
you know at the end of the day these
resources requests are used by the
kubernetes scheduler to run your
workloads and it's kind of important to
understand how this works so you can
tune your containers correctly so let's
say you want to run some pod on your
cluster assuming the pod specifications
are valid the kubernetes schedule will
use round-robin load balancing to pick a
node to run your workload so kubera's
will check that if the node has enough
resources of fulfill the request on the
pod containers if it doesn't then it'll
move on to the next node if none of the
nodes in the system have resources left
to fill the requests then pods go into a
pending state by using google kubernetes
feature such as the node autoscaler gke
can automatically detect the state and
then create more nodes automatically and
then if there's an excess capacity of
nodes the autoscaler can scale it down
and remove no to save you money so
kubernetes scheduled these pods based on
the requests but a limit can be higher
than the requests right so this means
that there in some scenarios a node can
actually run out of resources and we
call this an over committed State so
when it comes to CPU like we said before
kubernetes pull starts at throttle napot
each pod will get as much as it
requested but you know it might not be
able to go up to the limit it's hard to
drawing it down but when it comes to
memory kubernetes has to make some
decisions on which pods to kill and
which pots to keep to your free up
system resources otherwise the whole
system will crash so let's imagine a
scenario where we have a machine that's
kind of running out of memory
what will kubernetes do so kubernetes
will look for pods that are using more
resources than they're requested so if
your containers have no request at all
and by default they're using more than
they requested because I requested
nothing right so these are prime
candidates for termination another prime
candidate are containers that have gone
over their requests but are still under
the limit so if kubernetes finds
multiple quads that are gone over the
request then kubernetes will rank these
pods by priority and then terminate the
lowest priority pods first if all the
pods have the same priority then
kubernetes terminates a pod that have
gone the most over its request in very
rare scenarios kubernetes might be
forced to terminate pods that are still
within their requests this can happen
when critical system components like the
cubelet or docker start taking more
resources than were reserved for them so
why are kubernetes cluster might work
fine without setting resource requests
and limits we're going to start running
into more and more issues as your teams
and projects start to grow larger adding
route requests and limits your pods and
namespaces only takes a little extra
effort and can save you from running too
many headaches down the line I'll see
you on the next episode of kubernetes
best practices
you